do you think the biggest mistake that
young startups and young entrepreneurs
are making in trying to get new users
and this really really in just busy time
with social media like you're saying you
know I think most the biggest single
mistake that I see young entrepreneurs
making is two things one not realizing
that they're actually not an
entrepreneur right let's address this
right and this is a real real statement
this is a real tough one for me to say
because it's a very very it's a very
goosh bag thing for me to say but I
think it's an important conversation
that we have I think we're living
through a very attractive time to be an
entrepreneur
right you know [ __ ] you know Marc put
on a hoodie and a movie came out and you
know Instagram made a billion dollars
after 500 days and everybody decided
they were an entrepreneur the amount of
Ivy League school kids that I'm meeting
right now who think because they went to
Stanford or Yale or Harvard Brown what
have you or anywhere else obviously I'm
in the u.s. that think just because
they're smart students that they're
entrepreneurs that then I watch and the
first taste of adversity that they get
they crumble like a bunch of [ __ ]
[ __ ] and so I think the first mistake
we have right now is we have an issue
where people decided they're
entrepreneurs when they're not you know
I think that's the biggest problem
number two is people think it's a lot
easier than it is I mean listen the
press you for every Instagram there's
five million in stash it right and so